why is it that Russia and China weren't
that friendly under orange man why is it
that Russia wasn't invading Ukraine
under orange man well it might be that
orange man knew a little something about
leadership and about uh let's say how to
get countries to kind of behave the way
you roughly wish they would Tucker
Carlson was on the full send podcast a
couple days ago and he explained just
that
that Trump said he could close that in
24 hours if he wanted to do you think he
could I have no idea I mean he couldn't
build a border wall in four years so you
know there is a gap between promises and
delivery with all politicians very much
including him but I will say in Trump's
defense and maybe because he's a little
bit autistic he saw the stakes of this
like at the very beginning he's like you
don't want and this is what I do love
about Trump particularly in foreign
policy he sees the big stuff he's like
wait you've got Russia in China they
don't trust each other we can't let them
get together they'll kick our ass and
we'll be not We're not gonna fight a war
against them one hopes but we'll
definitely be taking orders from them
definitely no and he said that five
years ago and everyone's like shut up
racist
but is he wrong like what what do you
address the question shut up racist
he's a racist all right got it but he's
is if we start a war by proxy against
Russia Russia will align with China it
will be like how do you do you think
that's true or not shut up I mean they
would never address it and that's when I
was like whatever you think of trump
these people are speaking in bad faith
they're stupid they're also the ones who
got us into the Rock
do you see why the machine's always
going after Tucker too
Tucker is really good right there Tucker
did what I think anyone who is honest uh
would do it's what I try to do here you
know at first they're talking about the
wall Trump promised the wall he didn't
get the wall so maybe he can't do all
the things he wants nobody is above
reproach nobody is above criticism I'm
getting a lot of pushback suddenly on
the on the Twitter machine maybe because
I'm spending a little too much time here
too uh because I've been uh defending
DeSantis related to the whole Trump
nonsense but what he's saying there is
okay so he got some things right
something's wrong but he did see the big
picture on this thing that we could end
up in this weird proxy war and thus push
Russia and China closer together but
it's not just that Trump had the right
instincts on this stuff it's that our
current leadership in DC the compromised
befuddled buffoon Joe Biden who's
obviously not in charge and then the
Litany of diversity hires and half
crocked swamp creatures that he has put
into positions of power either have no
idea what they're doing or are in
intentionally trying to destroy our our
alliances wreck the economy etc etc
[Music]